et
j'ai mal à la gorge mois en plus ça fait
deux ou trois jours que ça dure et je
vais prendre rendez vous chez mon
médecin alors adresse mail
prénom
nom numéro de téléphone
mais pourquoi il demande tout ça c'est
vraiment nécessaire c'est une bonne
question mais faut pas que certains
malades allez on va essayer de
comprendre tout ça rendez vous dans mon
cabinet enfin je veux dire dans mon
atelier
[Musique]
toutes ces questions que l'on me pose et
les renseignements que je dorme sur mon
identité civilité adresse date de
naissance sont souvent nécessaires pour
créer un compte et accéder au service
d'un site internet ou d'une application
c'est ce qu'on appelle lé données
personnelles et c'est grave docteur
françois non tous des ports comment cela
est fait et de quelle donnée on parle
pour le moment on parle de données
personnelles on reviendra sur les
données de santé un peu plus tard même
si cela paraît anodin l'ensemble de ces
données personnelles en disent beaucoup
sur nous parfois plus qu'on imagine
lorsque vous donnez votre adresse on
peut en déduire le quartier dans lequel
vous vivez les endroits que vous
fréquentez à proximité de votre domicile
les commerces les lieux de loisirs votre
niveau de vie et ces informations
constituent une source de renseignements
très utiles pour certaines entreprises
en récupérant vos données quand vous
surfez sur leur site elles peuvent vous
adresser des publicités ciblées
concernant des produits plus adaptés à
vos besoins si vous avez été en bretagne
dans une maison par exemple on aura
plutôt tendance à vous proposer des
produits liés à l'activité nautique ou
au jardinage des palmes une tondeuse un
longboard un internaute qui lui a élu
domicile dans les alpes recevra
davantage de publicité liée à la
randonnée ou au ski une fois qu'elles
ont collectés ces informations avec
votre accord certaines entreprises
peuvent tout à fait légalement les
revendre à d'autres qui pourront elles
aussi vous faire des offres
personnalisées et ainsi de suite raison
de plus pour faire très attention où
vous cliquez et ce que vous autoriser ou
non ouais je comprends pas il ya plein
d'infos que je ne pensais pas fournir
commence at-il tout ça et comment
font-ils pour les récolter et bien grâce
au fameux cookies notamment jeu n'ont
jamais de cookies moi je préfère les
madeleines mais non je ne parle pas de
ces outils
10,1 cook et informatique c'est un
fichier texte qui s'enregistrent dans le
navigateur de votre ordinateur il est
généré par le site web que vous
consultez et il permet par exemple de
mémoriser vos mots de passe pour vous
connecter sans avoir à les taper à
chaque fois les coûts qu'ils
reconnaissent également vos préférences
linguistiques globalement ils sont très
utiles pour améliorer la navigation sur
internet mais ils fournissent aussi des
informations sur votre activité pour
vous faire des offres commerciales par
exemple quelle page du site vous avez
regardé combien de temps vous y êtes
resté au final ils permettent de
collecter des données qui sont
personnelles mais certaines entreprises
recueil des données beaucoup plus
personnel c'est le cas des données de
santé elles sont dites sensibles car
elles fournissent des informations très
confidentiel prendre rendez vous chez
son médecin en ligne c'est déjà une
donnée de santé aujourd'hui le transfert
de ces données est au coeur du système
de soins qui facilite la mise en
relation entre le patient et le médecin
l'objectif étant de mieux gérer votre
santé et les exemples sont très concrets
plus besoin d'attendre que le cabinet
soit ouvert pour prendre rendez vous
parmi les données collectées on trouve
aussi les ordonnances délivrées
directement en ligne qui permettent les
prescriptions lors des téléconsultations
elle peut être envoyée directement chez
le pharmacien au bout du compte c'est du
temps de gagné pour le patient
et du temps le praticien on gagne aussi
oui allô ne quittez pas vous avez de la
fièvre
fini ça
avec la prise de rendez vous en ligne
ils reçoivent concrètement deux fois
moins d'appels et peuvent donc honorer
davantage de rendez-vous les fameux
lapins
mais non pas cela les rendez vous que
l'on oublie ou ceux auxquels on arrive
en retard sont beaucoup moins nombreux
60% - grâce au rappel par mail ou par
sms
[Musique]
en fait c'est tout le cabinet qui voit
son activité améliorer les personnes qui
sont chargées du sécrétariat ont-elles
aussi plus de temps pour se consacrer à
l'accueil des patients un chirurgien
dentiste par exemple pourra davantage
s'appuyer sur l'aide de la personne qui
l'assistent durant des soins et la
collecte de données réduit donc le temps
consacré aux tâches administratives
auxquelles le professionnel de santé ne
peut échapper c'est plus de confort pour
lui et il peut donc tout de suite
s'atteler à sa tâche première soigner
enfin bon sens on fait quand même des
informations de santé sur la toile c'est
vrai que derrière un simple rendez vous
médical il peut se cacher un tas
d'informations le motif de la
consultation la maladie les risques de
santé encourus on peut en apprendre
beaucoup sur le mode de vie des gens oh
là là je préfère fermer l'application
tout de suite et pas prendre le risque
j'ai pas envie que tout le monde sache
je suis myope comme une taupe
normalement nous depuis 2018 en europe
les données personnelles dont les
données de santé sont soumises à un
règlement le rgpp dès lors quoi le
règlement général sur la protection des
données suivez moi et en matière de
données de santé le rg [ __ ] est très
stricte la loi interdit formellement de
les revendre ou de les échanger dans un
but autre que strictement médicales
permettent aussi à chacun de mieux
contrôler ses propres données
concrètement on peut maintenant demander
à récupérer tout ce qui a été collecté
et si cela ne nous plaît pas on peut
même aller jusqu'à supprimer toutes ces
données c'est ce qu'on appelle le droit
à l'oubli c'est bien ça mais avant de
les supprimer quelqu'un peut-il avoir
accès à ses données de santé personne ou
presque sur le site de prise de rendez
vous les données fournies ne sont
accessibles qu'aux patients concernés et
à son médecin personne de petit touchées
car elles sont stockées dans des lieux
étroitement surveillées
les fameux datacenter de grands centres
d'hébergement de données à 3 de voir ça
allez on y va là je crois que tu rêves
un peu impossible de se balader au
milieu des armoires de stockage j'ai
essayé même pour le tournage de cette
vidéo est la bresse et l'accès d'un
datacenter de ce type ont été refusées
dommage ne sois pas triste tu devrais
plutôt être rassurés car c'est centre
abrite des millions de données de santé
de dizaines voire de centaines de
milliers de patients les miennes les
vôtres peut-être elles sont stockées
dans de grands ordinateurs ultra
protégée ça ne vous amuserait pas de
savoir que l'on peut y pénétrer comme
dans un moulin ce sont de véritables
forteresses ils sont surveillés
physiquement mais ils doivent aussi
respecter des normes de protection
française et européenne et avoir reçu
l'agrément
hds hébergement de données de santé un
label qui garantit que ces sociétés
prennent au sérieux la sécurité de
l'information et la protection des
données personnelles face aux pirates
notamment
à l'abordage
oui je répète à l'abordage à mon avis tu
ne vas pas aller bien loin comme ça
j'explique il y a des antivirus et des
pare feux partout pour éviter toute
intrusion les systèmes de protection
sont mises à jour régulièrement et même
si quelqu'un réussissait à franchir les
obstacles
il ne serait pas au bout de ses peines
les données sont entièrement chiffrée
traduite pour ne pas être lu les lettres
sont transformés en chiffres une
succession de 0 et de 1 généralement et
personne ne peut lire les données sans
avoir la clé de déchiffrement elle aussi
stockés en lieu sûr c'est bien beau tout
ça mais comment peut-on être sûr que ces
mesures sont respectés et qui vérifie
d'abord il faut savoir qu'en france
chaque grande entreprise qui traite des
données de santé emploie une personne b
leye au respect de la législation sur la
protection des données il existe aussi
au niveau national un organisme qui fait
office de gendarme
la cnil la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés vérifie
que les entreprises respectent toutes
les conditions pour pouvoir utiliser nos
données en venant par exemple visiter
les centres d'hébergement la cnil
recueille également les plaintes des
utilisateurs en 2020 par exemple elle a
reçu plus de 13000 signalement tout
donné confondues chaque plainte est
traitée et si les règles sont enfreintes
c'est la fonction assurée tenez l'année
dernière sur 247 contrôle aux amendes
ont été délivrés et ça peut coûter très
cher au total plus de 138 millions
d'euros mais avant d'en arriver là voici
quelques petits conseils pour éviter les
mauvaises surprises
on vient de le voir les données
personnelles nous facilitent la vie et
leurs usages sont bien réglementé et
comme pour tout le risque zéro n'existe
pas si vous avez un doute sur un site
internet vérifiez bien que la page de
consentement aux cookies s'ouvre dès
votre arrivée vous pouvez aussi lire les
règles de confidentialité pour savoir
exactement à quelles fins seront
utilisés vos données
et parfois votre meilleur ami peut vous
jouer des tours s'il est utilisé dans de
mauvaises conditions je parle de votre
téléphone portable ou de votre
ordinateur une simple connexion internet
peut être un risque alors afin d'éviter
de tenter les petits curieux
mieux vaut donc essayé de se connecter à
des réseaux sécurisés comme votre wifi
privés et éviter le plus possible les
réseaux wi fi des lieux publics
restaurants hôtels ou transports allez
un dernier conseil
même si les sites de santé font le
nécessaire pour protéger nous donner
c'est aussi à nous de faire attention la
vigilance individuelle est la première
des protections et ce n'est pas
forcément compliqué
complexifier un maximum les mots de
passe de vos comptes évitez les dates de
naissance de vos enfants le nom de votre
chien ou de votre poisson rouge c'est
trop simple
ces mots de passe peuvent rats il m'en
être piratés
oh je l'avais oublié celui ci j'ai
rendez vous demain chez mon chirurgien
dentiste allez je vous laisse j'aime
brosser les dents enfin bon je lui parle
quand même
[Applaudissements]